welcome to this video playing Thomas
tell us here with white and we'll
probably get some kind of Queens gambit
playing him a couple of times I don't
really remember any game I lost one
summer I have the feeling that this loss
was kind of kind of bad I don't know
let's see Marin semi love yeah I really
should study the slide a little bit more
I don't get can't this sound so often to
try to get by with something simple like
like this then maybe you can just go if
I've here trading down two to nothing
hmm yeah
Bishop d3 he might even have f5 now okay
jake snyder 6mm might be on ok if i take
everything on e5 we are probably having
just dead equality but his is output for
Knight f6 this is really a problem and
then you form
oh not good
before sir awkward awkward to meet maybe
I can go a groupie one mascot admission
perform as possible okay come on let's
play this the simple stuff IAM takes on
e5 we should be three is this a move no
one you can take on edge too
yeah this is really just nothing but
sometimes you have to play with nothing
genuine you have misplayed the opening
somehow well they make muddy fly i might
have Bishop f5 hmm okay
Bishop f5 we should be true for
completely more completely dead position
check I can argue that his so Bishop is
better actually no f4 and still it's
still equal
okay man just kinky to my guess it's
really too little to to do something for
him of course that's a very poor game
from my part just having nothing or the
opening and defending this slightly
uncomfortable end gaming but early that
was a bad time before I guess with e5
that this he had the threat of pushing e
four so I thought them I needed to be
realistic then what's this see giving me
the age porn I don't really know why he
did dad mhm I mean it's still equal but
not quite sure why he gave me the the
outside passer
hmm nine straight still okay for him I
mean so yeah go over to e3
hmm maybe I could have taken form
check
hmm
then he's going back or what is he doing
hmm
okay if I go into e1 is going King III
this is wrong okay maybe over to d2 King
c3 is this the point
thing is yeah I'm getting bishops it to
ya and here really has calculated that
now i'm getting the h porn going or not
they don't quite get it this what's that
so easy i have 3 i'm taking hmm i know
maybe maybe I was lost their possible
but didn't think it was so easy in
likely plated hmm
so I'm going to wrap this and then I'm
going back to the one and then to see to
time morning it doesn't even get to
sacrifice the bishop
yeah I was a child will gain by me but
somehow somehow I screwed up the Zen
game
yes probably cursing himself very
understandably
black resigns yeah there was really
terrible right yeah and this after he
five it's kind of awkward actually I
really don't have anything better than
trading down to this sense and game
which was equal at first but then I was
plated when I had thought by the way
this was my original idea but he just
has this even have five as an
interesting move this is this kind of
thing yeah but Knight f6 is simple and
again we form is I mean maybe I should
do so this kind of thing but it doesn't
feel right to me now okay I decided to
just liquidate the position no arrow key
one is I should even go a sugar booty
one or something check it's as if that
really is taking it a little bit to it
into the extreme okay it started out
equal but I mean here here's a simply
nothing going on and that was kind of
surprised that he that he gave me the
outside person maybe I should just take
g5 this is simple and go down for the
draw I mean yeah I didn't I
underestimated that here with at five
and it got really tricky now I care
pushed the pawn and he I'm probably
cheating yeah King f5 or King f6 and
then going over to g5 picking up the
pawn is right he just picks up the porn
end up in the game but he played this
and I don't I don't believe it engine
gives Bush we have three now with the
draw and maybe going around yeah like
Bishop we should see to Bishop g5 if he
takes it age 6
g ade with the draw ok why is this a
draw in the first place if i play here
he gets over here then it is draw
likelihood of a draw is indeed very very
high ok i pushed this he played a 4 and
the engine gives the win with what
however with here with King e5 and going
back again towards the pawn yes he can
pick it up he took however I took and
again yes he has to go back now and now
I can can draw just by I'm just just
barely you should be aid and then then
funky stuff like that just about
catching this pawn he did this however
should be one and now Bishop h7s sir is
again a draw yeah ok this is the way how
it is check unfolding and draw dear king
d to you played f3 up to f3 it's lost
and you spend a minute on that he has to
go here here here and now after age 7
again we get check we get to a draw now
let's say b5 something like this c4 we
should be too
and I get to destroy spawns after this
push we probably have a lost position
now yeah he resigned I could have tried
this this this and this is actually
still kind of tricky very tricky
actually bishop if i go here he is going
to get the pawn so i have to play the
computer move the waiting move Bishop g6
now this is losing so what is he playing
actually be five other than playing King
c2 probably
I know again had threatening this I'm
sorry hmm King be five I probably go up
King a fork in b2b five and takes him
and I check just about them to win poor
now you definitely could have continued
this yeah really bad gamer but
interesting end game at the end thanks
for watching